where are you feeling being a mom I
messed up - up - well yes that's the key
the key part it's been it's been real
it's a whole other ballgame Morena
Baccarin and Ben McKenzie hit the red
carpet at the Fox upfronts in New York
Tuesday their first red carpet
appearance since the Gotham co-stars
welcomed their first child in March it's
the most rewarding and the most insane
job anybody could ever have then as
amazing of a dad as Gordon is as a
detective well I don't know it depends
which which episode you're judging he's
a great dad no I'm a lot more easygoing
as a father than here yeah how's
fatherhood treating you though great I'm
loving it it's Ari it's a wonderful it's
a joy once we get your ladylove back on
screen what do you want to see from them
do you think that they can make that
relationship work yeah I think Jim and
Lee are in a complicated uh dance to the
end they'll figure out their
relationship as it goes along but it'll
have it's uh it's it's high points and
it's low points at least we know that
you guys are endgame in real life yes
where we're fine we're all good
Jim and Lee I'm not sure